this morning president Trump's former
campaign manager Paul Manafort is waking
up in jail a federal judge ordered man
afford incarcerated ahead of his trial
on charges that include bank fraud and
conspiracy after allegations of witness
tampering surfaced in special counsel
Robert Malloy's investigation of Russian
interference in the 2016 presidential
election President Trump tried to
distance himself from Manta Ford but
later tweeted that he thought the
judge's decision was unfair
we Jiujiang is at the White House with
the latest we took good morning good
morning Elaine sources tell CBS News man
afford is banking on a presidential
pardon to keep him out of jail
for the rest of his life in the
president's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani says pardons may be coming when
that Special Counsel investigation wraps
up a pretty clear message for Manafort
as he sits behind bars Paul Manafort
arrived at court in Washington Friday
where a federal judge revoked his bail
after prosecutors accused him of witness
tampering ahead of his upcoming trial
manna Ford and his Russian business
partner allegedly asked European
contacts to testify that their lobbying
work did not take place in the United
States manna fort will now remain in
jail until his trial on charges
including financial fraud money
laundering and false statements
concludes later this year they went back
twelve years to get things that he did
12 years ago manna fort worked for the
Trump campaign for nearly five months in
2016 but earlier Friday the president
downplayed mana forts role in the
campaign
you know Paul manna Ford worked for me
for a very short period of time he
worked for me what for 49 days making a
surprise appearance on the White House
North Lawn the president held an
impromptu press conference there the
first for a city president I think that
the report yesterday maybe more
importantly than anything it totally
exonerates me he spoke about the Justice
Department inspector general's report
that did not draw any conclusions about
the president but criticized James
commis handling of the FBI's Clinton
email in
I think he goes down as the worst FBI
director in history by far there's
nobody close and I think I did the
country a tremendous favor by firing him
on North Korea the president once again
touted the success of his summit with
leader Kim Jong hoon I have solved that
problem now we're getting it
memorialized at all but that problem is
largely solved and he explained his
recent praise of Kim whom he once blamed
for the death of an American prisoner
spoken so passionately about the
circumstances that led to otto warmbier
death in the same breath you're
defending now Kim Jong Un's human rights
records how can you do that know why
because I don't want to see a nuclear
weapon destroy you and your family
the president spoke for a total of about
20 minutes right out here he also
doubled down on his claim that Russia
should be reinvade to the g8 after it
was kicked out back in 2014 for annexing
Crimea something the president blamed on
his predecessor and he added he might
meet with Vladimir Putin this summer
Alain we judging at the White House we
just thank you